never forget your teammate that's a lot
of teammates to remember got a shot him
out man turnaround jumper catches right
berserk tonight
well you got a small on and we've seen
them take advantage of little mouse
knocking turtle breaks up the lob pass
went back to Brunson Dirk's second shot
of the game seven now he had eight last
night up top for three from Justin
Jackson there you go
in a revolutionary time of the game as
you see the knee bend and the three
Howard sent the NBA on a trajectory to
where it is now Morgan yeah people like
to say change the game there's only a
few that truly changed the game and that
guy he did it with another three did it
to back threes by Turk flu in the room
for dirty he found the next stop but he
tosses it in darts got eight the third
quarter those is the last one well he
started getting up under the deep end
you welcome all challengers Devin Harris
finds Dierkes open baseline yes sir the
eyes are on this end of the floor
yep for you and it's dirt freed up the
pail pat-down and he hits bull's eye
look down Street for this time
be rising in Union in unison those that
weren't already on their feet they see
Dirk up top and dirt over you bags got
it they go for the top of the key 20
points 10 rebounds they're gonna take
your barrel out there's a bit of foul
committed with forty six point eight
seconds left
the last shot made by jerk and he will
come off the floor for the final time
[Applause]
at the top of the telecast tonight we
said the precis end of an arrow is used
parts who casually in sports in it light
these days but tonight as this season
has ended this truly has been the end of
an era
that we'll never forget
the first basket dirt made was in
Oakland California against the Golden
State Warriors the last one he made was
at San Antonio Texas
top of the key jumpers that was his real
estate through 21 season shooting in
that rain to the floor
Jeff's skin weight is on the floor with
dirt right now here with Dirk right now
big German how does it feel good you
know wasn't really suiting up all the
way I wanted to add a couple great looks
and a first out but you know it was
emotional for me last night it was
physically and emotionally draining but
you know I left it all out there today
again representing the franchise in the
city that I love so you've had some
amazing memories on the road this year
the way crowds have treated you you end
it here in San Antonio MVP chance how do
you feel about the way San Antonio
treated you tonight
yeah you know if I don't end at home
it's kind of fitting the end here in San
Antonio you know what this place is
meant to me to my career
the battles we had they were they were
always our big brother beating up on us
and oh six sliding by them not the most
respect for pop and RC and and what
they've been doing and they've been
great for my entire career here you know
they're there they're always great and
what they do and what they stand for so
class act and that death video got me
really emotional before the game and
really want to think that a sports
organization for before everything for
pushing me every year and making me a
better player isn't even possible for
you to right now articulate to our
audience with the last 36 hours has been
like for you I mean I barely got any
sleep last night I was super excited
super surprised yesterday that's
obviously five of my heroes my idol
showed up out of nowhere
that guy's like that would even show up
for me you know what look guy from
wurtzburg that meant a lot and then
finally Derek what are you gonna be
doing tomorrow man oh we got exit
interviews then I got I got a little
German house thing where I got more
interviews and then I'm gonna let go my
family's here for a couple more days
friends we're all over the world
I'm gonna enjoy the Aten he'll probably
start slowing down my next week you know
get up in the morning take kids to
school pick him up in between a lot of
laying around and I'm just letting go a
little bit thank you for everything man
it's been incredibly [ __ ] thank you sir
boom there he goes Turk back to you
follow well thank you very much skin we
love you big guy
[Applause]